hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website column and today we're
going to be looking at the tiebreaker
section of the 2018 World Chess
Championships between Magnus Carlsen and
a Fabiano Caruana if you have not been
following along the Championship was
meant for 12 games they did play those
12 games but they were all draw also we
do not have a champion after the normal
classical rounds which brings us to the
tiebreaker they had yesterday off to
prepare because they were gonna come
back and they were gonna play today
until there was a champion that's
exactly what they did if you're not
familiar with how the tiebreaker is set
up they first start out with rapid chess
you get twenty five minutes on your
clock after every move you do get ten
seconds added they play up to four games
and see who has the most points if
there's not a winner after that they go
to blitz and blitz is five minutes on
the clock and then three seconds added
on after that we're gonna be looking at
the game from the rapid portion and
we're in specifically game number three
Magnus Carlsen playing the white pieces
he also played in game number one so
we're getting to it Magnus Carlsen
starts with pawn to e4 and then pawn c5
the Sicilian offense very interesting
from Fabiano he's so used to playing
pawn e5 Knight f3 and Knight f6 getting
into the Petra defense he has all this
memorized especially for fast chess
would expect him to play something more
like this just because he doesn't have
spent any time thinking about the moves
it's all memorized to him it's his
favorite defense but he decides to play
something different and goes with pawn
to c5 the Sicilian offense Magnus now
brings the knight to f3 pawn east six so
not your common Sicilian defense of what
we've seen in the past pawn to c4 so
very different from Magnus Carlsen is
well Knight to c6 pun appeared to d4 so
madness looking to push his advantage in
the center of the board pawn takes here
Knight recaptures and then the bishop
comes down here to c5 and it's always
good to think about what happens if you
take here you don't want to be taking
with your night here on d4 White's just
gonna have all the advantage in the
center of the board Queen takes on d4
and then how does black continue here
Knight to f6 is pretty bad because it
isn't pawn up here to e5 there's no good
squares for the night to come to even
Knight to h5 is met by pawn g4 this is
all going to be bad but if you don't
come here where else are you gonna go
pawn to b6 starting to open up for the
bishop to get involved Knight to c3
Bishop e7 Bishop e3 I felt like White's
just dominating the center of the board
so you always want to be careful
although you may look at and say oh yeah
I'm an exchange material on the board
things are even not always the case
especially when your opponent can
recapture and have a better position so
don't just take right away
Bishop comes down here to c5 and then
night to c2 now this is an interesting
decision for Magnus Carlsen I feel like
this definitely gives Fabiano the
Vantage here because he's starting to
control the center the knight coming
back here to c2 is not where Magnus
Carlsen wants it if he had another
option you know could have chose Knight
takes on c6 pawn takes here maybe the
Queen's come off the board Bishop up
here to f4 this feels much more
aggressive from Magnus Carlsen but he
decides to go with Knight to see -
definitely seems to be part of his
preparation for the rapid portion of
this tournament Knight to f6 attacking
of the pawn Knight up here to c3 just
development but also defending at that
Pawnee or castle on the Queen side or
King side Bishop here to e3 pawn to b6
just protecting this bishop here on c5
yeah Magnus Carlsen wants to exchange
right here there's gonna be a nice
central pawn for Fabiano controlling
this dark square in the center of the
board on d4 Bishop to e2 getting ready
to castle on the King side Bishop d7
just trying to control this long light
square diagonal also attacking one of
the center pawns of for Magnus Carlsen
castle on the Kings side and then Bishop
here to e7 and kind of look at it as far
as what blacks going to do he has one
semi opened file here on the C file so
it could have brought his rook over here
to c8 may be pawns who h6 if he wants to
block off this g5 square could also play
d six if he wants to but instead decides
to go and bring his queen here to e7
Queen to d2 from Magnus Carlsen Rick
over here to d8 rook to d1 so from
Magnus's standpoint there's one semi
open file open it's the D file so he's
just putting everything he has on the D
foul he has a pretty good setup here but
it really just comes down to can he
break through there's a backwards pawn
here on d7 Fabiana is gonna have to
defend that properly yes he does have
his own semi-open file here on the C
file so eventually he could navigate
here try to attack on the Queen side of
the board Knight to e5 Bishop takes an
exchange here on c5 and then pawn up to
f4 so while magnus carlsen did bring his
knights back here to see - and it seemed
like it was somewhat passive he has now
started to push up has the advantage in
the center of the board
Knight comes back here to g6 Queen to e3
pawn to d6 and then we see rook to d2 it
Manglish girls gonna have a couple
options he could maneuver his knight
over here to the King side or even
something like night to eat one night -
d3 is an option but instead decides to
play a rook to d2 so he can swing his
other work over here to d1 and have you
know all of his material attacking on
this D file also may not want to right
away he could eventually bring his
Knight - to f3 once it comes down here
to e1 does not want to block off all of
the mobility of the Queen here on e3
pawn to a6 feels like a waiting move
from Fabiano not really adding to
anything he's trying to do right now
does block off the knight coming to b5
don't really think magnus carlsen just
looking to do that plays rook to d1 as
expected going to c7 pond to b3 just
solidifying the pawn chain really like
manage Carlson's position so far pawn to
h6 slowly building up a defense while
magnus carlsen slowly building up in
offense pawn to g3 solidifying the pawn
chain on the Kings
rook to d7 if the other work wants to
swing over here to d8 he could or if he
wants to just spread his defense could
also come here to e8 as well
Bishop to f3 rook to e8 Queen back here
to f2 Knight to e7 just maneuvering a
little bit but you can tell Fabiano has
a cramped position over here he's really
just playing defense right now
Magnus starts the push he plays pawn to
h3 not as worried about protecting his
King right here he sees his opponent
back here not really being aggressive so
he says yeah I'm gonna go ahead and
start pushing I need to try to get the
victory here rook to d8 I felt like you
could have done this a while ago you can
tell when you bring your work over here
to e8 and then move it to d8 you're
really just buying time seeing how
Magnus Carlsen is going to the attack
and then tried to defend correctly
Bishop to g2 Knight to c6 trying to
maneuver to a more active Square pawn to
g4 so pushing even further Queen down
here to a5 9 to a 4 just stopping the
threat of the Queen coming down here to
a2 Queen comes back to a c7 and then
pawn to e5 so both sides equal in
material but you could just tell that as
way things are building up Magnus
Carlsen is going for a big exchange and
it starts with pawn to e5 now after the
pawn takes Knight comes up here to c5
captures rook takes rook takes you see
all this materials start coming off the
board and then Bishop comes back here to
a8 and had different options could have
taken the pawn here on f4 if you wanted
to maybe then the knight takes on b7 we
see some exchanging going on I feel like
this is going to be fine
for both sides but instead decides let's
go and leave more material on the board
this year back here to a8 pawn takes on
e5 and then the Queen comes down and
takes on e5 Magnus gets his knight
involved into the action up here tonight
to d7 attacking the Queen Queen comes
down to b2 attacking both the pawn and
the night here and queen up to D
6.now usually if you're playing magnus
carlsen you see him immediately abandon
ship on this night on sea - you know
that you probably should not attack the
hat night right here and that's exactly
what he does he plays night taking up
here on d7 you don't want to play Queen
takes on c2 because Queen up here - f8
King moves Knight takes here
pawns gonna take you can see starts to
gobble up more material putting a lot of
pressure not something that Fabiano is
looking to do so instead he takes with
his knight the Queen takes now the night
falls Queen up here to e8 after the King
moves then the bishop is going to fall
so Magnus Carlsen has the bishop verse
the knight in the in game queen down
here - a d1 king - h2 queen d6 King down
here - h1 and then Knight to a d4 so if
we look at and say who has the advantage
because there's pawn chains on both
sides of the board the bishop is going
to fare better you can just control more
of the board if the pawns are all in one
side of the board then you would tend to
favor the side with the knight but right
now - Carlson definitely has the
advantage Queen coming back here to e4
you just want to centralize your
powerful pieces like your Queens like
your Knights even your bishops they can
just control more of the board so that's
exactly what this does pawn down to f5
so Fabiano trying to get aggressive on
the Kings side with his pawns after the
pawn takes pawn recaptures Queen down
here to e3
Knight to e6 and then it starts to push
on the Queen side you can see that
there's a huge threat that Magnus
Carlsen has if you look at the pawns yes
it's 4v4 but it just seems more
difficult for the pawns on the King side
to push for Fabiana where - Carlsen he's
got 3 V 1 here and both this Queen and
his bishop are both lying down
protecting the pawns as they push so
definitely feels like he has a strong
advantage a knight here to g5 pawn up to
a c5 attacking the Queen Queen comes
over here to f6 and then pawn c6 what's
the one thing you have to do with passed
pawns you push those past pawns as fast
as possible and this is a tricky spot
for
Fabiano how do you really defend against
this night to e6 it's an attempt but
it's just so tough to stop all the
threats pawn to a4 says he I'm just
gonna start pushing up the board if we
can exchange here I have to pass pawns
how does Fabiano ever block that 9 to c7
trying to stop this one pawn from
pushing forward a queen here to f4 and
this is a very important square for the
Queen for a couple reasons one it's
attacking the knight so that's rule
number one
but 2 it also is defending this dark
square diagonal and that's important
because this King if it ever gets
attacked by the opponent's queen needs
to come here to h2 and have a safety
area if Fabiano could come down check
the King and they just start back coming
back and forth between you know II 5 and
a 1 and Magnus Carlsen can't block that
we could just have a perpetual check and
there would be a draw in this game so
having it on this dark square diagonal
is extremely important for Magnus
Carlsen 96 attacking the Queen Queen
comes up here to d6 and even better
Square now it's more centralized this
nights can't move or the Queen's gonna
come off the board it's gonna be even
more difficult to hold on to all this
pressure Magnus Carlsen has this also
still defends the dark square diagonal
Queen comes down here a1 and now you
could see King up here to h2 Fabiano
can't check the King anymore unless he
wants to give up his Queen which he does
not so we come down at night to a d4
pawn up here to c7 you can see things
are starting to crumble for Fabiana
Queen to a c3 Queen over here to a c5
queen III and then the pawn promotes to
the Queen on c8 now a feat that Magnus
Carlsen was deadly with one queen he's
even better with two after pawn to f4
Queen comes down here to g4 and Fabiano
resigns now this is game 3 from the
rapid portion of the tournament but just
a heads up Magnus Carlsen also won game
1 & 2 so he is the champion part of the
reason I think that Fabiano
you know wit for something like the
Sicilian defense although he is very
well versed in the petrel defense it
tends to be more draw knowing that he
needed a win he had to go for a very
sharp defense that's what the Sicilian
does for you but it also opens you up
for a lot of attacking lines and Magnus
Carlsen came out of the opening with a
better attack but that's why he's the
best fast chess player in the world
ranked number one and so that was part
of his strategy as many people are
assuming and he's kind of hinted at is
he was okay drawing in the classical
style he thought his opponent was a
little more prepared than he was there
was a lot of games that you could tell
he was spending a lot of time just
trying to defend correctly but at the
end the day he knew that he had the
advantage when it came to rapid or
potentially blitz and he won the first
three games didn't even have to play a
game number four so this was the final
game and the 2018 World Chess Champion
Magnus Carlsen is again the champion he
will be the champion at least for two
more years 2020 is the next championship
so congratulations to him Fabiano was
cheering form thought he would have been
a great champion especially to have an
American win it since Bobby Fischer
would have been huge but Magnus Carlsen
the guy's just too good does not lose at
this stage and it this tournaments
almost set up for his style to grind
down opponents so difficult to actually
beat him and then if you do get to the
blitz portion I mean good luck that the
guy is just so good so congratulations
to him thank you guys so much for
following along with all of the
tournament's coverage 13 days that we've
been going over this finally have a
champion finally get to see a win and
not not even huge mistakes which is
always nice sometimes there's a huge
blunder it's it's kind of even the
entire time someone makes him honor and
then someone wins but this was just
Magnus Carlsen slowly and steady
building up a better attack and at the
end of it got the best of him Fabiano
made small incremental you know mistakes
Magnus Carlsen took advantage
and got the victory so congratulations
again to him and I will see you guys in
a later video thanks again for watching